un dernier sujet sans aucun rapport
cette fois pour terminer une exposition
de robots c'est peu ordinaire c'est à la
cité des sciences et des techniques de
la villette à paris donc depuis le 15
juin les enfants sont invités à
construire eux-mêmes des robots en
pièces détachées à partir bien sûr de
pièces détachées bricolage ingéniosité
le résultat en tout cas est surprenant
et cet atelier ferme ses portes demain
soir alors dépêchez vous dit elle et le
reportage de gilles bouleau
robot pédalo au robot cabot robot
hystéro robur ramonage de grands
rassemblements de la jante cybernétique
à la villette se termine demain dernier
brut biel avant dislocation depuis la mi
juin la cité des sciences et techniques
et est devenu le rendez-vous des
constructeurs en herbe les mines il
enfants de 6 à 12 ans venus pour tenir
un pari construire en une heure et demie
le robot le plus fou le plus tordu le
moins utile possible à ma gauche le
stock de pièces détachées
à ma droite les ingénieurs c'est parti
sans trop se poser de questions
nous on essaye de droit et puis décide
articule avec quoi tu articule sa
bavette ou au sol et les peaux ravasi ça
marche comment la parole est requis
pensons qu c'est le marché c'est ça va
ressembler à foix en compte selon les
cas une inspiration ce rapport semblait
à ça la géniale invention du robot sucre
heures de fraises autre trouvaille venu
directement de jamaïque le robot rasta
un ingénieur en rupture de ban enfin mis
au point un engin idéal et qui a réponse
à tout le robot c'est 10 go celui qui
tire la langue
heureusement demain 19 heures tout sera
fini
enfin le robot du guerrier